thank you thank you very much that was
incredibly kind I'm really nervous I'm
used to other people making my words
sound much better than they are so if
you guys could please imagine that I'm
Colin Firth Maggie Smith that would be
great I should first thank you guys for
coming and say it's an absolute honor to
be part of this especially with the
other speakers this weekend it's a
privilege to do the same job as them let
alone share the same stage and I would
also just like to take a moment before
we kick off to remember and celebrate
the great and recently departed within
Goldman who famously said about
screenwriting nobody knows anything he
said that consistently throughout all
the definitive books he wrote about
screenwriting his films will be watched
forever and that's how long he'll be
missed 40 so when I was thinking about
tonight
I thought that instead of kind of a
potted orthography what might be more
useful is if I just picked one project
and talked it through Watson all all the
way from the first optimistic chat to
spotting the DVD in Poundland
I know I'm up here I know I'm up here
advertised as the writer Melanie or two
but the bodies are still warm on that
and they might be listening so I thought
I would tell you about the development
and making of the film a little while
ago the Best Exotic Marigold Hotel not
hopefully in a smug wake as it
eventually turned out okay but because
it was such a long and difficult journey
and there were so many times on the way
when it seemed like it wouldn't and then
maybe at the end we could see if there's
anything to learn other than dumb luck
and blind persistence so it started like
most of the best things they with a nice
conversation about something entirely
different the excellent producer Graeme
Broadbent and I were hanging out having
lunch
I was lamenting the fact that as they
got older the wisdom that I'd expected
somehow to be visited upon me still
seemed elusive and I wondered aloud if
when I hit my senior years I would still
be quite so clueless and we laughed and
carried on eating fish a couple of
months later a gram called do you
remember that conversation he said I
think I might have something for you
working title had optioned the book by
Deborah mugga called these foolish
things about a group of senior citizens
who retire to India Deborah had written
a couple of drafts herself but for
whatever reason working titled hit let
it go actually I say for whatever reason
but I know exactly why it's because no
one thought there was any money to be
made in a film about old people and in
that no one I totally include myself and
Graham none of us had a clue we just
liked it which might be the first lesson
anyway blueprint frames company had
picked up the option there was a
director attached let's call him
director one but don't look him up
that's know his name and a start date
but they wanted a quick polish before
the shoot I read the book hair at the
skirts I liked them both so I went to
meet the director director one is a
lovely guy I liked him hugely he has a
great way of giving him note you say I
wonder if you feel as I do that this
this scene is running a little long and
then when you say yeah I do think we
could cut it some he goes I totally
agree his work is not known for its
subtlety and the changes he wanted to
the script reflected this he had an idea
for a scene where the wheelchair of a
character we all hoped would be played
by Maggie Smith got attached to a bus
and she was dragged through the streets
screaming as she went I was pretty sure
I'd seen something similar in Only Fools
and Horses and I didn't quite know how
to make that work but I signed up to do
a six-week publish anyway what I didn't
know then was that I suck at six-week
polishes or polishes in general they
require a specific and forensic skill to
spot key flaws in the script as it
stands and to fix them and only then a
good example of this is Bill Nicholson's
brilliant pass on David Franz Oni and
John Logan script for gladiator which
introduced the notion that Maximus is
goal in life is not power but
for the death of his beloved wife giving
the film an emotional heft that was a
huge part of its success it turned out I
couldn't do that it turned out I felt I
had to retype every line and rewrite
most of them including even the title so
the result was that after my allotted
six weeks I gave the producer and
director the first 28 pages of the film
I thought maybe we could have a look at
the first four or five now which
actually didn't really change from then
to when we shot them thank you okay we
will be with you shortly
[Music]
we will be shortly
thank you for your patience your call is
important to us we will be with you
shortly
[Music]
thank you for your patience your call is
important to us we will be with you
shortly mrs. Greenslade thank you for
waiting no if you just stay on the phone
for a moment and talk to me just talk to
me I not even clear on it I don't
actually understand what it is I'm
trying to order is Wireless the same as
Wi-Fi and what do either doesn't have to
do with broadband mrs. Greenslade
since the account is not in your name
before we can make any changes we need
to verify details with the account
holder guy please speak to the account
holder I'm asking if I can talk to the
account holder you can't talk to him no
he's dead he died of a heart attack
there's only me Lord Justice Walton
requests the pleasure of our company
how'd you forgot
I hate retirement parties crap cheese
crap wine endless beaches why do people
do that nobody nobody ever said about a
retirement party you know well this is
great I can't wait to have one of my own
it'll be yours one day one day very soon
you can saying that for years
as the recipient of faith I can testify
to the fact but neither actually
required surgery his relationship with
all his pupils was founded on respect we
respected him and he respected that
[Music]
this is the day grant
this is the day
[Music]
and there's an unlimited range of
leisure opportunities just a stone's
throw away so as I say what you're
looking at here is very competitively
priced you won't see better for your
gray pound another little feature not
necessarily right now give it a few
years rails on the wall to help you get
around and over here a panic button the
case of a sudden fall brings the warden
running what did we fell somewhere else
sorry it's just we might not manage to
plan our sudden fall in the exact corner
where the button is yeah and what is it
possible to have the rail going through
the middle of the room going to help us
get across as well as around um could we
have a moment please yeah thank you
thank you so much darling 30 years in
the civil service and this is all we can
afford
would it help if I apologized again no
but try it anyway
young lady I want to cover to you now
the trolley will be along shortly how
hard you have to fall to get proper
attention I've been lying here for hours
not a single doctor has come to see me
and that's not quite true is it mrs.
Donnelly a doctor did try and examine
you and you sent him away for that one
you can watch all he likes that colors
not coming out I'm on an English doctor
doctor why didn't you say so I'll get
one right away
mrs. Donnelly this is doctor good you
departed our notes please and after that
I worked as a systems analyst for a few
years but I just found it so dull what I
really wanted was City something more
creative that it matched I'm sorry um on
the food they asked for our age bracket
and the age we wanted to meet in other
cases I took 25 to 39 that's right I so
did I don't stop you mean you were born
in the early forties Joe do me trust me
I've still got it I can't find anyone
that wants it
I'm normal this is crazy you're crazy
you can't just up and leave like this
and yet if you watch me that's exactly
what you'll see happen what's going on
your mother's lost it I've never had it
you talk to her she doesn't listen to me
nobody listens to you I still don't
understand what's going on it's just a
stood a baby sitting now she says she's
leaving
but you love babysitting I loved it last
night we have peace and stay lovely
I'm the night before we had Tony's and
stayed up late if you don't go tonight
we could do a chorus it's tempting
darlings but you know I have to leave we
know being here stopping her finding a
husband another one by granny
don't let the [ __ ] get you down how
many husbands have you had any way
including my own mother mother mother
not even the place darling where you
going no idea
that's really nice but it's not checketh
but it does a job and it sets up the
characters first and thankfully to my
relief there were some loves Graeme was
very kind about the pages if clearly and
rightly frustrated that there was so
fewer than the extreme weather
conditions in India means that you can
only really shoot there between October
and March and so because of my
incompetence we were gonna miss our
window that year it also meant that we
lost director one who departed for
Hollywood where I'm sure he's totally
agreeing with people even now Graeme and
I made a list for his replacement at the
head of which was John Madden whose work
we greatly admired but he passed so we
moved only one place further down the
list - director - director - is a lovely
guy I liked him hugely but as he warned
me himself he's famously indecisive and
terrible at expressing himself which are
unusual qualities for a director ones
that made for an interesting
collaboration at one point he gave me a
note so self-evident be baffling he
could only shrug and go even I don't
know what I mean by there thanks for
that but the script got better gradually
director - wanted it to be less of an
ensemble and more focused on one
character so I dutifully did that even
well disagree but on the good side he
hated the idea of a wheelchair being
dragged by a bus so out of that came and
eventually we had something ready to go
to cast which is a thing casting you
might think that it's no part of a
screenwriters purview but you'd be very
wrong today I have no doubt Shakespeare
would be asked if he could punch up
Ophelia to help get someone relevant and
just think about whether she might be
American she could be studying abroad
Hamlet does the unavoidable fact is that
you can't make your film without the
acting people that the finance people
think that the watching people will pay
real money to see in our case though
everybody doubted that we'd sell a
single ticket it was clear that to even
have a shot there was only one person at
the top of that list the goddess that is
Dame Judi Dench around him we should of
course erect railings the Judi is
fantastically loyal to people with whom
she's enjoyed working with before and
that doesn't leave a lot of time on her
dance card for new partners so I did a
sneaky thing I happened to be reading
Richard Ayers Diaries
his tenure as head of the National
Theatre in which he talks about
directing Judy as Gertrude in a
production of Hamlet on the first night
she sends him a card with a quote from
Great Expectations what larks pip so I
wrote the following scene actually can
we show that again because just out of
interest the guy in between them that
gets on the bus is not one of our extras
he's just a blow bill god bless him goes
just goes with it is that right if we
see that again
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah I've always wondered how long he
sat on the bus before realizing it was
never gonna move anyway a couple of
weeks after we sent the script out
Judy's daughter Finn T was reading it
one morning at breakfast and she got to
page 18 read that line and said oh you
must do this mum she talks just like you
actually as a postscript the day we shot
that scene several years later I was
sitting with Judy waiting well the
camera crew got set up and she turned to
me and said it's funny you know because
I do actually say this in real life
which was obviously my cue to go yeah I
know and I did a sneaky thing but
instead I went really I have no idea but
there's maybe another lesson which is
right to get a cast whatever that takes
so we had Judy we had the great Penelope
Wilton we had some momentum and the
window for shooting in India was just
coming around again we all felt pretty
good and then to everyone's surprise
most of all his own I think director too
suddenly made a decision he didn't want
to do the movie since I'd spent much of
the previous six months suppressing the
impulse to bury my burrow in his neck I
wasn't entirely disappointed by his
decision but it did mean that another
window slip by that we wouldn't be
making the film that year and that we
lost our cast which is no good nobody
was getting any younger
Graham and I regrouped reminded
ourselves that we'd actually always went
to John Madden and now we had a much
better script we were certain he'd like
so we sent it to him again he passed
director 3 is a lovely guy I liked him
hugely his background was mainly in
comedy in quite broad comedy so well I
tried my best to write the film he
wanted we weren't a great fit apart from
the day when I heard myself suggesting a
scene where Maggie Smith's wheelchair is
dragged along by a bus he loved that he
also thought we should focus less on one
character and more on the ensemble
lesson and so through the third year we
worked in reasonable harmony I was
getting tired by now
and at those times we required the
inspiration to come from our
collaborators which feeds the energy
back into us that wasn't really
happening with director 3 but after
several more drafts
we had a new script to go out and it
took us to the next level because Fox
Searchlight ranked to say that they
liked it
this was excellent news as they're good
people who made
great films they were lovely about the
script although like us they
acknowledged that it was a commercial
risk making a film about elderly people
in the third act of their lives unlike
us their solution was to suggest that
the leads should be played by Pierce
Brosnan and Emma Thompson this was a
tricky moment I wrote a passionate
letter saying that those actors would
pass and they'd be rated because I
didn't know what that hotel was if they
didn't want to make this film I totally
got it after all no one else did but if
they tried to turn it into something
else then it really would have no chance
at all the point was taken thank God and
we moved on searchlights next action I
agreed with slightly more to gently
nudge aside director three when that
deed was done we all had a meeting and
talked excitedly of John Madden finally
all the elements had lined up perfectly
we hadn't improved scripts and excellent
casting options and we were now financed
by a studio so we sent it to him and he
passed as did another Indian window and
another year director for I have to say
I liked somewhat less than hugely this
was at least as much my fault as his I
was getting sick of the film by now a
six-week polish had taken nearly three
years and I didn't have much left to
offer also director for had absolutely
no interest in it being a comedy which
on the good side meant that we lost the
scene where a wheelchair is dragged
along behind the glass but also we lost
pretty much every other joke as well he
also thought it should be lesser than
ensemble piece and focused more on the
lead character but despite my issues
with his vision of the film I look back
on my behavior in the meetings at this
time with some shame as I was so
unhelpful and truculent is to be
actually juvenile although he started it
he's smart though director for and there
were some good things in the script
there were enough things for Judy to
come back in single handedly torpedoing
the studio's hopes of a younger cast
because who can say no to the great Dame
pep Wilson came back to and others
arrived such as Tom Wilkinson and Celia
Murray and there was a glorious day that
I got a message I would come to regard
as typical from Maggie Smith that she
would do the film on the condition I
made it a bit better
but he was tricky and fussy and a
research trip to India revealed a fatal
mismatch between him and that glorious
country as everyone here trying to make
a film knows it's hard enough to get the
rock up the hill but if there's a lack
of conviction anywhere about what you're
doing you really have no chance as the
window approached yes again I don't
think anyone really believed we were
going to go there and shoot a movie so
we didn't and that was the end of
director for Churchill defines success
as the ability to move from one failure
to another without loss of enthusiasm
this is a standard I spectacularly
failed to meet when Graham called me
early the next year so he said about
marigold and I just couldn't the horse
is dead I told him stop flogging it it's
an X horse it has ceased to be
he was as all great producers have to be
remorseless as water torture I was
thinking maybe we should offer it to
John Madden were his last words before I
hung up two weeks later he called again
John or as I like to call him director v
was in he'd read the latest draft and
well he missed some of the jokes he'd
found a deeper and more truthful than
any he'd read previously so there's
another lesson here I think what I'd
thought for the previous few months had
been only backward steps turned out to
be partly sideways ones offering at the
very least a better chance to move
forward but I was down I was very clear
about they're thrilled about John loved
the idea of the film he might make but
the script needed new energy and I
simply didn't have it just coming
meeting so Graham he's lovely you'll
like him hugely so I went and we met and
I explained why I was executing myself
from the project there was nothing left
that could happen between these
characters know where they could go no
arrangements of words in the English
language that I hadn't had them say to
each other a thousand times over I was
written out it was the first and only
time in our friendship that John
completely ignored what I had to say and
as he started to talk and talk about the
film he wanted to make I felt
sufficiently buoyed by his inspiration
enthusiasm and belief in me to agree to
do just one more month's work on the
film just over a year later we wrapped
production in Joker
I had been a jun side throughout the
whole process he believes that the
directors most important relationship on
a film is not what the lead actors the
cameraman or woman or even the editor he
believes it's with the writer and he
proved that everyday it's useless you
knowing that because he's literally the
only director that ever lived that feels
that way so work with him I guess is the
lesson you know he also went to
descriptive focus less on the lead
character and be more of an unsolved and
I never even bothered to pitch the
wheelchair behind the bus but maybe the
best example of his touch and tone was
what he got me to write for the ending
four years the big climax of the scoped
had been Bill Nighy running through the
crowded streets to Jaipur through the
Holi festival where people throw paint
dust at each other he arrives back at
the hotel looking like a very handsome
rainbow comically out of breath as he
tries to make a passionate speech to
Judi which somehow does the trick and
she falls into his multicolored domes I
loved it all the directors had loved it
John didn't let's take it down a little
dead boy he said less running I said and
less paint he replied I rewrote it less
romance was his note this time I rewrote
some more then some more just less he
said would you want to talk about is
having a cup of tea perfect he replied
so I wrote this
[Music]
[Music]
you're still here I missed the plane
what about Jean she didn't
I had I had quite an interesting night
actually I met the same taxi driver but
this time I let him take me to his
brother's hotel which turned out to be
less of a hotel him and more of a more
of a brothel
really and then I gave me this pipe said
it was Apple tobacco but that's not what
they call it when I was assumed so so I
made my excuses and left I need I needed
time to think
this city at night is extraordinary
I think the Apple tobacco helped
I get be late to work what time do you
finish I get back about 5:00 to time yes
how do you take it with a little milk
thank you that's John not me that's of
course he was right the cameras rolled
on draft 38 of marigold hotel and there
were a couple more during the shoot
itself but the work paid off we had
ridiculous fun making the film Judy as
she described the experiences of life
changing and when you're 78 to describe
anything at all his life changing is
just massively cool and then to her
astonishment people went to see it and
they saw it again and again we had a
theory that older people went for repeat
viewings because they'd already
forgotten the jokes it so they could
laugh every time as the first sound like
goldfish the thing about a sight Geist
is that unless you're really smart which
I think we've established I'm not you
don't see it coming but if you're lucky
enough to be on that wave to be giving
people something they want and need
right at that moment you really just
have to not screw it up it's not for me
to judge whether we just didn't screw it
up we did any better than that I
remember when I got home from India
friends with us what I've been doing out
there and I described the film by saying
Judy Dench and Bill Nye fall in love
while Maggie Smith wanders around being
racist in the background and everyone of
every age was like I'll see that so
maybe all the work all the drafts all
the deadlines and directors notes
mattered way less than the fact there
was just a brilliant idea of Debra's in
the first place with a wonderful cast in
a fabulous location well maybe just
maybe in this business where we're all
so endlessly frustrated by the process
this film is an example of the process
actually working with every iteration of
the script
that it went through just leading up to
being ultimately the best version of
itself I like to believe the latter
partly because we all worked so hard but
mainly because that means it can happen
and that I guess is the final lesson
thank you so much for this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]